so if you haven't heard today we started
streaming the show live on YouTube baby
that's right cumin on YouTube and you
can watch the show happen every day
between 1:00 and 4:00 central - and 5:00
Eastern and it is streamed all three
hours so be sure and step in you'll be
able to get incredible insights of
things that go on behind the scenes what
Kelly really looks like when she's not
letting you on the air in the lobby and
you get to see people like these folks
right here in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions Logan and Rachel are with us
hey guys how are you hey Dave welcome
welcome where do y'all live right fruits
borough just at the room just neighbors
about 30 minutes away then very cool
well it would not counting traffic but
anyway anyway so welcome good to have
you guys
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream yes I love it and how much have
you paid off seventy-six thousand three
hundred thirty and eighty seven cents
oh very good is that your house and
everything that's everything Wow and how
long did that take 19 months boom just
like that yeah so range of income during
that time we started it was fifty three
thousand a year combined and now we're
up to about 75 very good what do you all
do for a living
I'm an x-ray tech in an MA we're a pain
management company okay I'm a
firefighter and EMT okay very cool very
cool
so how much of the 176 was your mortgage
the majority about 6,000 of it was
school loan for her and the rest of it
was our primary residence and then
another home that we owned that we were
written out and owed on okay so
something's not working tell me what
happened here because you did not make a
hundred and seventy-six thousand during
that nineteen months no we got gizelle
intense for sure I took it to heart when
you said sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next okay I don't have
kids yet but I told her the neighbors
were getting nervous
we sold our first home that we bought
together and moved out to our little
farm out in the country that we were
written out okay she already had another
piece of real estate that you sold and
what did it sell for it sold for about
159 okay so that helps okay yeah now my
mouths working again yeah but you made
the decision
move down really in lifestyle from that
home into the little place of the
country yeah
simplify forever very cool very cool so
how many anchors have you got quote in
the country about eight very nice good
nice very good very good
and so you sold 150,000 our property
moved on to the other so what's the
place in the country worth about 115 120
okay yeah it's just got a double white
on there right now and we'll build out
there someday yeah yeah well before you
know it because you're on the house
payment right completely weird right I
start drawing plans yeah yeah and start
saving towards that as fast as you can
absolutely
so what made you guys get this radical
what happened nineteen months ago that
flipped the switch in your life well we
were both in jobs that we didn't like we
were exhausted we come home tired and
just felt stuck one weekend she was
working for a mobile company and she was
working 16 hours Saturday and Sunday and
she got stuck out on the road one night
broke down and she had a terrible boss
that left her sitting in a rough spot in
Nashville for about five hours
so I load it up and drive to Nashville
ready to take names you know and yeah
had some guys in my inner circle kind of
chilled me out just said look there's
got to be a better way to move on and
that night I went home and opened up the
financial piece kit and started writing
down a budget and figured out we've got
to start attacking this because we can't
get out the jobs nothing like your wife
getting stuck in that bad neighborhood
to wake you up right did you quit the
next day I was there for about another
year oh wow okay because we couldn't
afford it so I figured out that night I
said we can't afford to quit either one
of us we wouldn't be able to eat much
less make a mortgage yeah Wow
and you put the house on the market then
shortly after yeah we're trying to sell
that the property on the farm and it
just wasn't going so we just decided to
flip-flop and and sell the other
properties dead alright cool so what was
the key for you all that caused you to
be able to be debt-free nineteen months
after you get stuck in that rough
neighborhood teamwork I think we really
had to sit down and make the decision
together and look at the numbers
together and know what each other was
spending in
just conference basically you know what
I heard I heard you decided there was
some stuff in your life that you didn't
want to trade that you were willing to
trade so that you didn't be stuck in
that neighborhood again yeah you not to
work for a jerk right and I'm willing to
trade some of that stuff and before that
night maybe you weren't yeah maybe not
yeah we had talked about it and I think
but it changed the seriousness side
we're gonna get serious and hey we want
our life back now I'm here I don't I'm
gonna get in a position I can tell him
to take this job and shove it
yeah and because he needed it almost did
I mean my gosh it's unbelievable
so yeah I don't blame you for that you
had some guys call me down I'm not sure
I would have it yeah yeah that stuff
it's unbelievable so yeah it's pretty
incredible so how does it feel now kind
of surreal I don't know it's starting to
sink in but it's when it's not even two
years mmm since that night and you just
boom you have a completely different
life all right
completely you took your life by the
neck and just held it and said you're
gonna behave yeah we needed some control
in our life self-control you know yeah
we had to go for it sometimes something
has to happen like that that that could
be the best thing that ever happened to
you because right clearly not only did
it cost you to change this but it taught
you that you can't just coast along you
got to pop stuff man you got to hit
stuff my absolute and you when you do
that stuff moves but if you just kind of
look at it wish it moved it didn't move
that's right and that's a neat part of
your story you guys are rock stars
very well done you got to feel great
absolutely right absolutely now are you
working this well together before I
would say so but I did definitely
spurred us to a new level of
communication of teamwork I mean she
kind of brag on her a little bit was my
little rock star she'd spend every
weekend she'd sit down and write our
menu out for the week go grocery
shopping two sometimes three different
stores to make sure she didn't spend any
more and she had to and prep all the
meals so we didn't have you know just
kind of get lazy and stop out somewhere
and buy something yeah so that was very
encouraging I mean big breakthrough
right there that's huge yeah
well congratulations you all very well
done I'm proud of you
thank you neat folks very fun Logan and
Rachel from Murfreesboro Tennessee
and $76,000 paid off in nineteen months
including the sale of their old place in
the paid-for country place they're
living in awesome stuff fifty three
thousand a year up to 75,000 a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
very cool very well done that's how you
do it right there hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind